hey what's going on spill Birds time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
April 24 2017 how's it going all right
how you doing how's your week I'm sorry
the podcast is a little late I traveled
today I flew back from Boise Idaho not
Boise everybody there's an S in there
that's what I learned when I was up
there Boise Idaho and you know what's
hilarious when we when we landed when we
landed it you know that uh the [ __ ]
shooter you know on the plane the
shooter I don't mean with the gun
because you can't get guns on the planes
unless you make one let go
what's-his-face there John Malkovich and
that Clint Eastwood movie what was it
called God so what it's called you made
like that little plastic gun till I get
some god damn respect any [ __ ] hung
up the phone no just I'm not talking
about a gun the [ __ ] the shooter the
guy the wedge breaker it's like the
second they ring that little Bing bong
man you can take off your seatbelt some
guy from 12 rows back like runs up to
the front of the plane so of course he
stops right on my roast and I can't get
up but I'm looking at his dad gene that
he was wearing flip-flops all right so I
got to give it up to the guy all right
you know to show that kind of quickness
with like you know a third of a shoe on
was it was impressive
so this [ __ ] guy who was in the row
behind me diagonally across starts
[ __ ] sharpen in his ear it was like
the [ __ ] NHL playoffs I'm like if you
guys going to drop the gloves I see him
talking the guy threw the guy you know
the flip-flop guy looking over his
shoulder right it's basically a guy with
really nice shoes and polkadot socks in
first class which is where I said I am
that's I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm flying to Las Vegas I sit in
the front of the [ __ ] plane it's just
how I do it
all right I spent 20 goddamn years in
the back of the plane I swear to god I'm
not going back then I just spill the
[ __ ] tea all over the planet what did
he like what are the odds that I was
putting my wallet on the [ __ ] string
to the tea bag into this [ __ ] shit's
going to go all over the place it's just
for the gun I'm having a hell of a like
[ __ ] four days here we got damn thing
every little [ __ ] thing that can go
wrong you know first I break my computer
screen head and then the teabag comes
out my Jesus Christ that's going to take
me at least 11 seconds to clean up or I
just kind of wipe it up with my sock
what a [ __ ] animal I said I stopped
it from going down the side of the table
don't judge me so anyways let's get back
to the polka dotted polka-dotted socks
all right [ __ ] gentleman worked his
way up to the front of the [ __ ] plane
oh maybe he was born into money I don't
know I don't think this guy was because
he was [ __ ] all over this [ __ ]
animal with his flip flops who was
coming up from you know the [ __ ] the
animal section of the plane where this
guy deserved debate all right
telling you right now you that should be
your guy's goal in life you got to get
to the front of the [ __ ] plane and
that that's not a metaphor that is it
literally you have to get to the front
of the [ __ ] plate unless you don't
travel that often than just you know
suck it up who gives a [ __ ] but if you
travel all the time you have to get to
the front of the [ __ ] plane and I'm
telling you the only difference between
the front of the plane and the back of
the plane is they just they treat you
like a human being that's it that's it's
not like it used to be where you know
there was [ __ ] broads up there and
you know they'd meet you in the Eastern
Airlines [ __ ] lounge afterwards and
they you know you haven't liked a [ __ ]
it whatever the [ __ ] happened in 70
enemy credible meeting of pubes that
that decade was so elated this guy is
[ __ ] in the guys it like I you know I
got my [ __ ] the free [ __ ] Bose
headsets the wireless ones that those
Bose [ __ ] gave me and then I found out
they're spying on you if you have the
app I had to delete the [ __ ] app
Jesus Christ and then I found out those
guys in blue apron are like going down
to farmers markets they're going hey you
don't want to you know of you with these
guys come over to us you know what I
mean what a bunch of [ __ ] if that's
what they're doing allegedly that's what
they were doing why don't you [ __ ] go
do then that God
Ralph's doing a supermarket right stand
your own weight class you colored apron
[ __ ] [ __ ] hilarious this farmers
market guy was going off on him go blue
apron they eliminate the middleman he's
like Hello
you are the middleman you dumb [ __ ] we
eliminate it we farmed this [ __ ] we're
going right to the people anyways i
probably just lost a sponsor there but i
don't give a [ __ ] right if that's what
they're doing if you weren't doing it i
apologize to everybody that you know
wears an apron the color of my balls
right now okay I apologize anyways um
Jesus bill can you get to the [ __ ]
fight alright alright sorry I'm a little
distracted I don't like doing this
podcasts on dates that I traveled um I'm
a little a little scatterbrained ear
more so than usual alright before you
make a joke god damn my new computer
screen is gleaming I'll tell you
underrated breaking your [ __ ]
computer screen you know you take it
down you never go to the Apple store
don't ever go to the Apple store the
Apple store is like flying coach ok
you're going to go in there and they're
going to treat you like a [ __ ] animal
you know they put themselves on a higher
plane walking around genius right on
this shirt what does your shirt say says
nothing right like you have no [ __ ]
inside your head you got to go down and
go talk to those [ __ ] wiry [ __ ]
anyways now you go to some local [ __ ]
place you know they charge a little bit
more but you go in there ok and you get
treated like a [ __ ] human being so I
go in there and you know and they see
the busted computer screen they know
what the [ __ ] happened you know and I'm
not going to lie to him like oh you know
I got a little one at home and she
knocked it off the table the you know
doing that [ __ ] I didn't do it they go
what happened to it I said I stabbed it
with my phone so they start laughing
they go why'd you do that I'd say
because I'm an impatient person and I'm
not good at these things
and it seemed like the right thing to do
in the moment and I immediately
regretted it so now I'm here to give you
my money if you can
fix's and they were like absolutely you
know no it's funny cuz I always have a
piece of tape I have a piece of tape
over the [ __ ] camera so I don't want
people watching me [ __ ] jerking off
to porn I don't know I don't wanna watch
people meet muttering walking around
talking to myself in the hotel room
trying to come up and do Joe I doesn't
want people watching me so that's the
first thing I noticed was like wow this
screen is really clean and [ __ ] Big
Brother can see what's going on you know
I don't mind faking here what's going on
I just don't want him to see it so
anyways there's this guy he's got
polkadot socks on he's [ __ ] you know
just smart pair of wing tip shoes on and
he's just fun giving this guy [ __ ] so I
take off my Bose headphones you know
which they probably downloaded the
entire argument was [ __ ] spying [ __ ]
right so I take them off and he's right
in mid-sentence just walk right up here
you hit me with your bag what's wrong
with you what's aren't you I can't hear
what the other guy said but this other
guy the guy in first class you'd think
he'd say some [ __ ] guy with little
soft hands you know never worked a day
in his life
he's [ __ ] all over this guy to the
point the guy who you know the flip-flop
guy just turns his back and doesn't to
say anything and this guy just keeps
going going he goes what are you doing
actually gonna push down a kid you know
hey you might want to brush your teeth
too
he started giving the guy [ __ ] that his
breath stunk I was like I [ __ ] loved
his done [ __ ] love the gun just
[ __ ] just the entire time it took him
to get the goddamn jet way over this guy
is just in his [ __ ] in his [ __ ]
ear and the guy wouldn't drop the gloves
would not drop the gloves during the
playoff unbelievable you know like he's
some star player right he's gonna he's
gonna he actually hurt the teams he
[ __ ] sits down the shooter man you
know I wish what happened I wished he
grew I grabbed him by his backpack
because I don't give a [ __ ] if you have
if you [ __ ] have a black belt in
every martial art discipline if you have
on a backpack it's [ __ ] over because
all the person has that once somebody
just grabs your
backpack and starts running the other
way there's nothing in jiu-jitsu there's
nothing in Aikido you just can't you
know that's why it will you watch the
UFC and Joe Rogan will tell you this
that they do not allow backpacks into
the Octagon for that specific reason you
don't I mean the backpack it's like the
gun as far as like just just throws the
black belt right out the window you know
I mean you know like all karate movies
like nobody can have a gun because then
it's just kind of like well yeah I can
just show you you know that's the coward
way up or the cinchy way up
remember that really oh you can do it it
since she that's what I was a little kid
that was a word that just disappeared
meant easy I guess it's a cinch became
sin she just took it out [ __ ] 48
years later I finally get it
anyways I just wish I reached up grabbed
his backpack and yanked him back past
into the polka-dotted sock guy and
everybody just passed him right back to
his [ __ ] rope would have been
tremendous you know and I know a lot of
young listen to this podcast and I could
lie to you and say that pre 9/11 that
was the America bag that I lived in you
know well you know like you could sit my
house and not have to worry about
somebody from the Geek Squad watching me
[ __ ] rub one out you know in the
privacy my own goddamn home I have tape
over every [ __ ] thing I could find
they can listen but the kids think
that's the deal if there's no video just
like the podcast no [ __ ] video in my
living room right now the guy I got my
TV they had the little [ __ ] camera up
there not [ __ ] doing that I want to
look at some [ __ ] pimple-faced douche
and play out War of the Worlds whatever
these kids do you know or the world's
worst [ __ ] Warcraft minecraft mind
head what is it called as a video game
transcended video gamers to the point
that I extreme isn't it witches of
Eastwick what is that that's what that
[ __ ] game that everybody loses their
by when it comes out that Warcraft
something like that
don't come to me now well whatever
that's how you just guess I get out of
your own stupidity that's such a great
phrase that will come to me why didn't I
know that back in the day when I was in
math class you know what is the sine
cosine and tangent of that [ __ ]
hypotenuse mr. Byrne oh it's uh don't
tell me now you know what LLL come to me
it'll come to me now my teachable ain't
fair enough
and maybe I went had to go to summer
school two out of four years I should
have gone off three [ __ ] I shouldn't on
all four years here I mean my sophomore
teacher let me off the hook and gave me
a d-minus
and then senior year I was like well
what's the point what's the [ __ ]
point let me get into a better Community
College yeah didn't make any [ __ ]
tips you know I mean it's like when the
[ __ ] outfields playing in you know
and then the guy after the plate he hits
it over the guy's [ __ ] head he doesn't
go get it he just runs it that's why I
treated summer school my senior year not
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] what's the point
when I can go out and get hammered drive
drunk and do what you did in the 80s
just driving around hammered hammered
you go down to the [ __ ] liquor store
the [ __ ] as we called it hey go down a
path you get me a sexist dope we go down
to the [ __ ] store right you just stand
there out front you know D hands in your
pockets looking as conspicuous as
possible and then you just [ __ ] walk
up to adults and be like hey could you
buy me some beer you were you know and
there was no fight there was no cameras
back then the television had just been
invented I mean nobody knew how to work
these things and people would do that
they would actually like not even think
about the liability they would go out
they you know you try to judge like get
a buyer that's what it was you try to
like try to like pick the right person
somebody look cool you know anybody in a
suit you like [ __ ] that guy not asking
you don't ask a mom you know didn't ask
any women you go to me like she hoard it
up a little bit you like he didn't got
to make a judgment call how involved in
her life was her father
I don't know I don't know now I'm not
doing it I'm not doing and you just wait
for something a little bit long hair you
know some [ __ ] shitty little mustache
you look for dirt bags basically what
you did someone who would have no
concern for people underage driving away
with alcohol and that's the way it was
done I don't know what I'm talking about
right now in orders I got these [ __ ]
helicopters in my ears can you hear that
think they like hovering right over my
house they having a big parade right now
a parade or something
it's the Armenians they're recognizing
are remembering everybody who died in
the genocide you know you know I just
realized that just really just [ __ ] up
my relationship with the Turkish funny
book probably won't be getting any
weekends out there for a while
then Ken's a cursed Ana wherever the two
countries are they trying to act like
yeah we did we never did that
ah that never happened yeah well the
rest of the world knows it did so you
can just sit there deny it all you want
you [ __ ] Bernie Madoff how long are
you going to [ __ ] lie about this [ __ ]
I actually watched this documentary
speaking of just despicable horrible
things to do to human beings you know I
don't know anything about Turkish people
but I'll tell you right now I did they
were probably scared shitless of
Armenians you don't I mean it's [ __ ]
tough people that's probably what it was
they got all nervous or some [ __ ] I
don't know what it was it's a lot our
meetings in my neighborhood I swear to
God like every other one of them you
look at you like is that is that a UFC
champion like the [ __ ] jack their
heads are shaved every one of them just
looks like they could kick the [ __ ] out
of you I don't know maybe Turkey got
nervous I have no idea what happened I
don't know how you could [ __ ] do that
I don't know the older I get the older I
get the more sickening human behavior
becomes not saying I'm some [ __ ]
saint but yet I still for the life of me
do not understand how war is
legal I just don't I don't get it you
know let's let's let's wait into
international waters here without really
paying attention to anything I don't you
know I don't even watch the BBC you know
what a lot of stuck-up [ __ ] over here
do I just want to get another
perspective so Syria gasses some of its
own [ __ ] people and then we shoot
missiles at them so my thing is where do
the missiles go and who died how
accurate are those missiles was that
just some guy selling popcorn on this
corner of Syria in Kazakhstan you know
he's up there step right up step right
up and we're like I sorry about that
sorry about that we were trying to get
the guy that did the thing that we
didn't like that we frowned upon we
would like to apologize to anybody at
the food court I've no idea our our
missiles that good I don't know I have
no idea I just don't get how that works
get Wars just really I just don't I
don't understand it we're going to
murder more your people before you
murder all our people and then when we
win we're going to say that you guys are
evil right the only ways if somebody
just starts with you if they started you
know then you got to finish it I guess
that's how it works you honor me then
Sean Connery make a speech about this
and the untouchables or something like
that I don't [ __ ] know but I don't I
don't get why we're all up in arms about
that hairless fat [ __ ] over there in
Korea you don't to me I just don't I
don't understand why this guy can't
shoot off his fireworks with his own
[ __ ] country I mean we do that [ __ ]
all the time
who gives a [ __ ] what is that [ __ ]
dick gerbil gonna do that's what he's
built like
it's built like a gerbil he just adds
like a [ __ ] yeah he's adorable if he
would just stop with the I'm going to
blow up [ __ ] in the United States you
got to admit the guy he's kind of
adorable you know I don't know I have no
[ __ ] idea but anyway so I was
watching this thing on Europe
right after World War Two and then I it
was so fascinating to me what the [ __ ]
was going on that I actually you know I
went on I actually got on my the
Internet I didn't have my laptop because
I stabbed it with my phone but my phone
was still working so I was checking out
you know a couple of websites and this
one website put exactly how my mindset
was how I believed World War two right
after was like all right I mean I knew
in Germany that obviously they had to
[ __ ] rebuild you know obviously Japan
was a rough one right I knew that they
you know we're rebuilding but everybody
else I kind of died you know everybody
was all in a good mood and [ __ ] and
skipping down the [ __ ] Street because
it was over his website put it you know
there was sailors kiss and nurses in
[ __ ] Times Square that was it and
evidently it was not in a lot of ways
like people were acting exactly the way
against the people they were fighting it
was [ __ ] brutal there was all kinds
of rapes murders people settling scores
all Germans that were all around Europe
that had you know were not in Germany
they were getting [ __ ] killed and
sent back to Germany a couple of little
mini genocides which you know between
people in eastern [ __ ] Europe it was
just like Jesus Christ I'd say some of
these two [ __ ] Nazis too
every time I think like I've heard the
worst thing they ever did it's like you
littered you can't even watch it I just
found out something else they did i'ma
tell you it was so [ __ ] disturbing
I'm not even going to repeat it I can't
stop [ __ ] thinking about it and then
they were showing the goddamn Nuremberg
trials and those [ __ ] Nazi countries
sitting there with this arrogant look on
their face like well this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know and then I'm thinking how could
you think that how could you not be like
what clock that got a little well guess
we got a little sideways with that a
plan huh did [ __ ] sitting there you
know with these look on their face like
yes look like this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm thinking like how could they
possibly think that because they're
probably I'm thinking they think whoa we
[ __ ] won you guys would be sitting
here all right what about when you
firebomb Dresden how about that [ __ ] and
then we could just be like well you know
we wouldn't have done that if you
wouldn't do what you were doing if you
weren't doing what you were doing right
mr. blonde they'd just done what I told
Ms oh no one would have been dead that's
what we were doing if you didn't do what
the [ __ ] you were doing we wouldn't done
what we did and then they would say well
we what we did we learned from you with
what you did to the Native Americans and
then we would say well you know what
that wasn't us we weren't alive when
that happened and then they'd be like
well you know what he is still alive and
a lot of them are still alive and you're
not doing anything about it
and when we like alright fair enough you
know what we'll set some emotion to
eventually give him our casinos and the
Nazis would be like you know fair enough
fair enough
and that's a you see say hell all his
[ __ ] footage of them hanging these
[ __ ] guys just a nonchalant way they
did it did this footage of this guy I
don't know what the [ __ ] it was it was
like it was just a board it was like a
do-it-yourself [ __ ] hang the guy
right in court they [ __ ] tight a guy
his hands behind his back they lay him
down on his board it just goes like to a
45-degree angle they hoist a guy up
they put a [ __ ] rope around his neck
and he's sitting it [ __ ] all of them
up right and then a guy with gloves just
covers the guy's eyes and then they let
go of them and as the guys slide down he
breaks his neck and the guy with the
hands just he just moves his hand with
the guy's head so you never see his
[ __ ] eyes you know because they don't
want to upset people in court
[ __ ] insane [ __ ] insane and Jesus
Christ I gotta be honest I really wish I
didn't watch it because there's this
woman testifying and that that that you
know if you want to see it I can't
remember the program I'm sure you can
find it on the [ __ ] Internet
you know just google what the [ __ ] was
Bill talking about World War two I'm
sure somebody will find it and you got
to see them like it you know um all
right this is just not funny anymore
all right let's plow ahead let's talk
about something else okay so I was there
now I was in Boise this uh not Jesus
Christ so I'm typing my password here I
was in boy you know what does anybody
seen uh Joe McEntire's new show Joe
McIntyre from New Kids on the Block from
the movie the heat I got to work with
Don with him on that that movie and he
was [ __ ] great guy absolutely
hilarious right so I was supposed to do
a podcast with them to help promote his
show and I had I just completely forgot
and he drove all the way over to this
podcast studio and I wasn't there
completely [ __ ] the guy over so he's
going to be I'm gonna be interviewing
him for next week's Monday morning
podcast and he is going to give me a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ] so out of guilt I'm
like [ __ ] I got to watch this guy show
because I [ __ ] this up and I put it on
and lo and behold it's [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious
okay I'm not gonna let e I hit pause
because I wanted to make sure that I
said this guy's name like Joey Lawrence
did a guest star
I always forget there's too many Joey's
in the story so I [ __ ] I was going to
[ __ ] it up he was [ __ ] hilarious and
the guy who plays is uh aging is great I
don't know what his name is
I'm on the IMDB page I'm gonna [ __ ] all
of this stuff up everybody on the show
is hilarious Jamie Denbo who I also
worked with in the heat and who else was
in Donnie Wahlberg all of these guys
were just it's really [ __ ] funny
thank Christ because I was already
sitting there going like [ __ ] I [ __ ]
this guy over I didn't show up and then
I'm gonna watch your show oh my god god
what if it's terrible
then what do I do I gotta sit there
across the great show I can actually
take it's a [ __ ] great show I don't
know what network it's on I'm going to
[ __ ] the but I'll know by Monday all I
know is it's not on the comfy network
but it's [ __ ] hilarious just look it
up it's really really well-written and
the guy who plays his agent is a [ __ ]
beast kills it and I don't actually
found it interesting to like what his
life is like you know because it's based
obviously on his life and there's so
much like creepy older women wanted to
come up and hug him and now we've got to
kind of just allow them to do it
I found that hilarious just because I
don't like people touching me you know I
just after a while I just like I so
understand how he meant Bill you know to
me just as people always wanted to come
up and touch him and then like what if
he wants a [ __ ] sandwich
in all those hands he just shook all
that DNA he could literally start his
own country with what is on his [ __ ]
hands and when you really start thinking
about that you know that's I don't know
like my favorite time to meet people is
during the winter when I'm back east and
you already have gloves on I love winter
when you're in New York you know you can
go on the subway you can grab on to [ __ ]
you can finally hold on you know
just walking down the street high-fiving
homeless people
well you don't give a [ __ ] right you got
on gloves it's perfect
maybe that's what I'm going to do you
know I've always been looking for
something oh look who's here I might be
into love no no no I haven't done that
the podcast yet oh it's the two lovely
ladies can I say hello to my daughter
what's up huh huh oh you know what the
internet doesn't work in the office and
I was worried I was going to stab my
laptop again with my phone I didn't want
to do that come here let me get one
little smile here let me get one little
smile hey buddy
oh she just woke up did you just wake up
hey remember me yeah there's that smile
how are you all right she's too adorable
and this is not going to be a funny
podcast anymore how are you cutie we
gonna hang out today huh we a couple
beers nice smile
back back out sorry I'm back I'm back
all right let me do some of the let me
do some of the Regis oh yeah check out
our return of the Mack yeah how fun is
that show there you go see that Nia
would never lie all right let me let me
read some of these [ __ ] things here
where is all right okay here we go all
policy genius life insurance do you have
it if you don't why not too expensive or
a hassle man I actually have life
insurance now and I'm [ __ ] excited
you know I can't tell you how relaxed I
am on planes now now I know that if I
die it doesn't matter I have rendered
myself like just I know I've just sort
of delegated everything out to this
point that I'm just sort of useless
all right policy genius calm the best
online life insurance marketplace the
most accurate
from the top a rated life insurance
company's policy genius has placed over
five billion dollars in life insurance
for people like you Jesus Christ I
wonder how many of the people are going
to get murdered in that five billion do
you ever think that there is a fine line
me--it now that I have a great life
insurance have you ever thought about
often me huh creepy creepy [ __ ]
answer all right policy geniuses has a
very simple user-friendly website to
shop and compare all the top rated life
insurance companies and give you the
best options they have a licensed
customer service team to help you find
the best policy at the best price while
you're there check out their other
insurance office offerings like pet
insurance now Jesus Christ just flush it
down the toilet go to policy genius.com
today to save over 40% is there a reason
the door is open with those dog gone
helicopters all right oh my god she just
she just put my daughter in the little
swing set thing over there all right now
the tone of the podcast has to change
hey buddy
never seen a kid smile so much like that
alright go to policy genius calm there's
a kid in the room people to save over
40% off other prices for life insurance
when life insurance insurance compete
for your business you save money that's
policy genius calm please spell it out
okay pol I see why GE and I US minute I
cannot do a podcast with a baby in the
room you knew that when you met me zero
jargon zero sales pressure zero hassle
man life insurance made easy free quote
zero hassle peace of mind don't wait go
to policy genius calm today oh look
who's back it's our old friends old zip
recruiter hey I wanted you to do the
recruiter part
you ever know your wife's mad at you
just by looking at the back of her head
are you hiring why do you know where to
post your job to find the best
candidates posting your job in one place
that's not enough to find quality
candidates if you want to find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
on all the top job sites and now you can
with zip recruited com you can post your
job to 100 plus job sites including
social media networks like Facebook and
Twitter all with a single click find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll in to zip
recruiters who ease busey easy to use
interface no juggling emails or calls to
your office quickly screen candidates
rate them and hire the right person fast
find out today why old zip yeah it has
been used by Fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses and right now my listeners
can post jobs on zip recruiter for free
for free by going to zip recruited comm
/ / that zip recruited comm / / what
this dot-com / / all right what do we
got here
is it only one more Oh beautiful hunt
the great thing about [ __ ] on
advertisers aren't you get less and less
and it's less reading out love alright
he looks everybody hellix your unique
you know walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else sir Trey life right
Michael Oher sleep like anyone else so
why is your mattress one size fits all I
don't know it still it feels good I
don't know these guys give me anxiety
like I thought my aunt my mattress was
fine this is a classic sales technique
scare the [ __ ] out of them create a need
because it truly customized mattress
will cost you five to ten thousand bucks
who the [ __ ] has that kind of money I
bet that guy with the polka dot sock
stuff you know I loved about him he
wasn't afraid getting sued either is
that on my screen Oh No okay until now
okay go to helix sleep calm answer a few
simple
and they'll run a 3d biomechanical model
of your body through proprietary
algorithms as they develop with the help
of the world's leading arrogance and
biomechanic experts the result an exact
replica carbon copy [ __ ] AI robot
shows up looking just like you and
you're like wait but you're me and then
it stabs you in the throat with the
[ __ ] ice pick but not before your
mattress arrives you will be one of the
most well-rested murder victims of a
robot the world has ever seen the most
comfortable answers you've ever slept on
telex helix customers report a 30%
improvement and overall sleep quality i
I don't I don't understand how you know
I guess how you feel when you wake up
how's it feel but yeah it feels yeah how
much better I you know I don't know 30%
30% sounds like a lie they said like 27%
I'd be like okay no but that's something
people would say they pick a round
number all right you know what I believe
them all right and four couples they
customized each side of the mattress
that's the beginning of the divorce by
the way your mattress arrives at your
door in about a week and shipping is
100% free and you and your wife can
begin the slow drift apart like the way
the continents separated right just it
all starts with my mat I want the
mattress to feel like this I want it to
feel that way and you know it works in
relationship you know somebody has to
cave but not anymore thanks to hellix
sleep breaking up marriages for over 30
years on your mattress arrives in about
a week and its shipping is 100% free
that's why everyone from GQ magazine oh
Jesus GQ magazine oh my god get out the
moose to Forbes ah the banker [ __ ] are
all talking about hellix sleep you have
a hundred nights to try it out gruff and
if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for free yeah and give you a hundred
percent refund no questions asked
whenever I pictured them picking it up I
always picture [ __ ] Jesse and mr.
white showing up in their hazmat suits
go to helix speaking of Boise right
Aaron Paul he's from up there go to
HELOCs week.com slash bar and get $50
off your
that's helix sleep calm / / Telex sleep
calm / / ok anyway so let's get on to ok
so I was up there I am going to talk
hockey but I'm trying to avoid the pain
I'm trying to avoid the pain okay I just
thought about covering this way it comes
to bed I related Kleinfeld is my friend
that's that's one of my favorite roles
Sean Penn ever played
I [ __ ] love him in that I love him
with the [ __ ] perm and the receding
hairline and I was doing the [ __ ]
blow cop comes in she says all that
crazy [ __ ] to him trying to scare the
[ __ ] out of him
he just looks to the cop and goes doc
done done [ __ ] hilarious
oh I love Sean Penn you know sometimes I
pray for a flood just so I can see him
coming up in a boat just to rescue me
he's that kind of guy anyways so I'm up
in Boise Idaho working with Jibson
theatre had a great [ __ ] time despite
the fact for the first time in like 12
13 years I had to kick somebody out of
the show and I never do that
and I told the guy I don't want to do
that I think it's a [ __ ] move by a
comedian deal with the heckler and
that's it but this guy was just he just
was you know he wasn't even remotely
coherent and I don't know I offered to
pay for his tickets and all that I was
just like dude you just you gotta go you
gotta [ __ ] go and I gave him I got
one more work you could just shut the
[ __ ] up and he still is that is I could
I could even respond to what are you
saying cuz I couldn't understand him and
it was getting uh it was getting ugly
getting ugly so you know I apologize to
the people there and if the guys
listening you know just come back next
time sober all right
that's all I didn't want to do it
alright I'm sure you woke up today I'll
[ __ ] mad at me
you know when they threw him out they
found 14 beers empty beer cans
underneath his uh underneath the seat I
don't know
they're trumping up the charges I don't
know because he was in the front row a
bunch of rows of beers cans rolled down
to him I have no I don't pretend to
[ __ ] know but anyways I was um I was
performing at that theater and one of
the coolest things anybody has ever done
for me
the people at the theater heard that I
play drums
so they rented a drum kit and during the
day I got to go into the theater the
theater and just [ __ ] you know put on
my Walkman whatever the [ __ ] he call it
the iPod thing my phone my little
handheld stereo and just [ __ ] just
rock out man I had a great a great time
and whoever the whoever tuned up those
drums they sounded great the snare was
[ __ ] unbelievable like it was like
I'm marching I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was it was like six and a half by
like what's the next size up I'm sorry I
was like fourteen by six an app what's
the next size up is it eight inches deep
nine inches deep but this isn't a point
over here people I'm [ __ ] asked it
was incredible incredible [ __ ] sound
and that was his old ludwig's and they
didn't even have like the usual like
lugs on them whatever the [ __ ] you call
the things you unscrew when you're
tuning up and tuning down the drum or
whatever attention any tensioning the
drum will have the [ __ ] he's supposed to
say they just had screws that were all
stripped so it's got this great kit but
to adjust it I had to take out a pair of
pliers that came with the drum kit
those a five piece broke it down to the
four piece set up to Steven Adler
[ __ ] setup they fell in love with
when Appetite for Destruction came out
you know when I was going down the
slippery slope if I want as many drums
as possible because I was listening to
Iron Maiden and then Steven Adler came
on like this [ __ ] guy's getting more
music out of these four drums and half
these guys out with these [ __ ] 15
piece kits so I just I had I had the
greatest [ __ ] time and was up there
with Rose Bowl tailgate legend Joe
bartnik who [ __ ] murdered all week
and Monday morning podcasts producer
producer
so they said extraordinary and new
stimulus was up there and we made a tour
we did a tour of Boise we [ __ ] it we
got everywhere we got [ __ ] everywhere
we went on the blue field we went up to
the [ __ ] Table Rock we were all over
that [ __ ] town we had a great time so
that will be coming out the San Jose one
is almost done and then I also got
another one for San Antonio that's
coming up so I'm just going to start
doing those [ __ ] things I don't know
why I like doing them but fun you know
plus it makes me get out and do [ __ ] you
know
then the Boise a number of times I never
got up into those [ __ ] hills you know
so alright I think I've avoided it long
enough let's talk about the NHL playoffs
[Music]
ah you know you want your team to make
the playoffs
until they lose a playoff series then
you just like I'd sucked shouldn't they
just not have made the playoffs they
could just rip the emotional band-aid
right off congratulations I'm saying
this to gritted teeth congratulations to
the Ottawa Senators it was a well-played
series I had nothing about rest wreck
for you guys in your organization good
luck in the next round against New York
for good right and and I got a you know
you know they always do the star of the
game I mean at some point you got to
give it to those all those Ottawa locals
you know that were refereeing those
games particularly Game three Game five
even a little bit of Game six you know
I'm not saying it you know I'm not
saying that's why we lost but jesus
[ __ ] christ all I wanted was a little
consistency you know it is a deal a
reskin [ __ ] you in one game but you know
when it's like three out of the six
Jesus quite how many times do we have to
win Game five before they create a score
like two [ __ ] goals the [ __ ] sit
in the crease covering the puck up in
the crease not the goalie okay for those
you don't watch hockey that's I've been
watching - for 37 [ __ ] years that's a
penalty shot
they have replay I don't know how they
mail well after further review when the
defenseman put his hand over the puck we
could no longer see the puck so it was
inconclusive as to whether it was
underneath the glove or not so we
actually won Game five despite the
[ __ ] refs trying everything they
possibly could to give Ottawa a chance
to [ __ ] win it game three was a
debacle you know end of the third period
I came who the [ __ ] it was someone on
Ottawa just stood haven't punched one of
the Bruins in the face and we got
offsetting roughing we both got two
minutes for roughing the Ottawa guy for
punching to do in the face and I guess
de Bruin for not ducking I don't know
what I don't know we got two minutes for
not ducking for allowing yourself to be
punched in the face I have no so is also
the guy that's what he's going to do
what I saw that I was like okay this ref
is like it's going to be even strength
I'm not going to be a part of this
horseshit okay I don't know why he
punched him in the face maybe some other
should happen right before that this is
retaliation I don't have time for your
[ __ ] [ __ ] children you're both
sitting down it's going to be even
strength and no one's going to know my
[ __ ] name at the end of this but
that's not I went down because then in
the [ __ ] overtime Ottawa comes in
[ __ ] smashes us in the face Nash
punches the guy back in the face and we
get two minutes they go on the powerplay
the [ __ ] beat us I don't I'm not even
saying that we would have won the
[ __ ] thing but it's just like well
what why do that to me now I got to
think of that the whole [ __ ] summer
can't you just let Ottawa beat us they
were going to beat us maybe they weren't
I don't know I don't [ __ ] know but
Jesus Christ I even thought that last
that last one maybe I'm looking at this
some [ __ ] black and gold [ __ ]
colored glasses which of course I am I'd
love to hear what you think even like
that [ __ ] you know they want on the
powerplay again on some ticky-tack
[ __ ] horseshit it looked bad when you
looked at the [ __ ] when I did anyways
let's be honest when I looked at the
instant replay
it's like posture knock was trying to
get to the guy with the puck who was
entering the offensive zone
aka a [ __ ] scoring threat the [ __ ]
Ottawa guy turns around looks at posture
naught and initiates the contact
posture reach out grabs the guy and he
just sits on his ass
two minutes for [ __ ] holding [ __ ]
30 seconds later hey enjoy your golfing
but you know what what do I do I mean I
actually I have no [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] about Ottawa at all I go there I
have a good time I do shows they've
never done anything to us for some
reason they decided to trade Chara to us
so thank you for that so god bless you
on your [ __ ] wing but now I get it
but you know something as sad as that
was I was equally happy for the New York
Rangers not because I like I don't
dislike the Rangers I actually like the
Rangers in front of a few New York teams
that actually kind of see I really love
actually love the Knicks and I love the
Rangers unless they're playing us then I
don't like and it's not really even them
and so it always comes down to the fan
so I was extremely excited that the
Rangers knocked out the Montreal
Canadiens but of course I cannot give a
hundred percent credit to the New York
Rangers I do have to thank the fans of
Montreal who are in the Montreal Forum
the second forum on that fateful night
when you guys absolutely humiliated
Patrick wah to the point he gave you
guys the finger right remember that then
he went over he sat on the bench and he
looked at your owner and I've read his
lips he said listen you [ __ ] I'm
never playing for you [ __ ] again all
right trade me to whoever the [ __ ]
Nordiques are now and that's what
happens that's exactly what happened he
called it and then he went on anyone two
more cups
I believe in 96 and in 2001 or was a
2000 I can't [ __ ] remember right and
the greatest thing ever is month of
Montreal Canadiens never won another cup
the end that's it that's how the story
ends that's right now that's how it's
going to end I love it
they dead do you believe it I'm
literally I've room for a franchise that
has six cups you know but we won in
2011's but that gives me that gets me
right
you know whenever Montreal fans talk
about their [ __ ] all the cups they
want I just started singing glory days
that's all I do it's really obnoxious it
annoys the [ __ ] out of them they start
wiping their tears away with their
little hankies they have in the front
sport coat pockets I was actually
talking to bartnik and a host of puck
off and I was trying to tell him I was
you know saying that I was going to root
for Toronto so of course then they get
the old right there Fred from [ __ ]
the Capitals by the way hey Bill who do
you think's could win the Cup I think
the Penguins repeat that's what I think
that's what I think I think they can
have an amazing [ __ ] series against
the the Capitals and then they'll
probably face the [ __ ] Rangers and
who they're going to face in the West
well who the [ __ ] knows now nobody saw
that four-game sweep against the
Blackhawks and I mean no saw that [ __ ]
come [ __ ] people in Nashville you
know they actually did such not hockey
fans they actually showed up for Game
five they didn't know how many games you
had to win that's such a cheap joke but
I enjoyed it
congratulations to Edmonton who else
moved on Anaheim and I'm [ __ ] kicked
the [ __ ] out of somebody st. Louis blue
you know I guess I got a room for the
Blues again I'll root for the Blues even
[ __ ] they've never won a cup and did
anyways I was talking to bartnik Joey
blodnik
and a lot of people don't know this
because the Maple Leafs have not won
since 1967 and I was surprised when I
was going back one day just going down
some [ __ ] hockey history rabbit hole
and do you know in 1967 like if you ask
somebody like who the greatest hockey
franchise the most successful one of all
[ __ ] time it would still would have
been the Canadians right they've still
won the most cups but a lot of people
don't know this in 1967 the [ __ ]
Maple Leafs were only one cup behind the
Montreal Canadiens they are now ten cups
behind them or something like that 11
cups by believable yet 24 213 in 1967
the [ __ ] Toronto Maple Leafs won
their 13th Stanley Cup to be within one
of the Montreal Canadiens so that's like
Celtics Lakers except the Maple Leafs
weren't lying about any of their titles
they didn't win one and some other
[ __ ] Hockey League you know and then
they called it a Stanley Cup
championship you know anyways so they
win it in 1967 all right the Canadiens
have 14 Leafs have 13 that breathing
down their [ __ ] necks if they win two
more right all of a sudden they're the
greatest [ __ ] franchise of all time
that's how [ __ ] close they were and
once again they aren't they won the Cup
in 67 the end that's the end of that
book it's [ __ ] unbelievable
and then the Canadians they wanted the
next two years in a row 68 69 then the
Bruins won at 70 oh god here we go this
is from memory the summit was [ __ ]
nerding I'm 71 the Canadians Wednesday
me to the Bruins
73 Canadians went then the playas went
back to back in 74 75 and then they
[ __ ] headed Canadians headed dynasty
76 77 78 79 Larry Robinson beat the [ __ ]
out of Dave Schultz you know both of
them rockin the same [ __ ] firm both of
them I believe had a mustache I mean it
was it was 1976 you watch it now they
look like a couple of roided-up hipsters
but back then that's what men looked
like and he stood up to him and that was
it that's one of my favorite [ __ ]
moments by the way that's a de Bruin fan
I love that fight you know just because
you know I don't know I just don't like
bullies and I'm not saying Dave Schultz
is a bully so if you're playing [ __ ]
hockey for [ __ ] sakes
me we do mean to me you know but
whatever they would call the police it
was just something about it like I just
saw him pulling people's hair and [ __ ]
and I was just like a you know whose kid
no I love Dave Schultz but after a while
you went so many fights you can start
rooting for somebody else anyways then
they won in 86 then he won in 93 they
won ten more [ __ ] Stanley Cups and
just they just disappeared over the
horizon it was like when Lance Armstrong
look back at that guy you know
and he went on went on to win the Tour
de France like seven [ __ ] times I
still can't believe they took those
titles away from him it's so [ __ ]
ridiculous that's one of the dumbest
things ever that whole [ __ ] sport is
on drugs
they're all on drugs so was a level
playing field okay that's it I'll tell
you right now if they all if the same
people raised okay and they all went
clean he's going to win it again right
he's the best guy they're all on drugs
that was even better that whole thing
[ __ ] him annoys me you know why cause
everybody [ __ ] shits on the guy but
everybody made all this money off of him
you never saw anybody give any their
[ __ ] money back did you oh they were
so [ __ ] outraged like the [ __ ]
[ __ ] who run the sport of cycling
didn't realize what the [ __ ] was going
on you know what I mean if someone if
someone you work with if you're in a
restaurant and somebody's on [ __ ]
heroin at the staff you know the people
in the restaurant don't know but you
[ __ ] know because you work there they
let that guy when seven in a row blow up
the [ __ ] sport and then they took it
away from and they all kept their
[ __ ] money that's exactly what
happens far as I'm concerned you know
why doesn't Trump go shoots and missiles
at them you know um anyways I mean what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about let me let me
uh [ __ ] type in my goddamn passport
passport my password oh the screen is
just so cool I never [ __ ] wiped down
the screen [ __ ] animal I am never do
it I just I'd rather squint for some
stupid reason all right let's do a
couple questions here all right big eyes
follow up hi Bill I listened to your
podcast when you were going when you
were googling big eyes and heard you
mentioned the fiasco that occurred
which you dismissed assuming that it
wasn't the same artist actually there
was a fraud involved the husband took
credit for the wife's artistry which
came out after the images were licensed
love your podcasts love you go [ __ ]
yourself and by the way I am a 62 year
old woman and I've god bless you
sweetheart
yeah I actually looked it up yeah that
guy was a [ __ ] creep well we should
put a link up to that it's a crazy story
my favorite part of that story was I I
forget there was some big [ __ ] you
know one of those things that like
socialites show up to you knows people
who are just you know they're famous
because people go to these parties where
famous people are there and everyday
only they just have a great conversation
you know they're going in they talk
about [ __ ] hot-air ballooning or just
something just I don't know the day just
people just find them fascinating
because they can go from subject to
subject you know while eating appetizers
and not getting anything between their
teeth they just I don't know what it is
about [ __ ] rich people they are
fascinated I think they got so much
[ __ ] money they just get bored right
and God knows they're not talking to
their wives anymore you know they went
out and they got themselves a mattress
that you know two different kinds right
[ __ ] banker he probably wants a
heated one the reptilian [ __ ]
so I think I know if it was the World's
Fair I don't know what it was but they
[ __ ] bought they had all the think
they bought some big one of those
big-eyed [ __ ] kid paintings and
somebody in The New York Times or one of
these [ __ ] papers that all these
[ __ ] socialite [ __ ] want that
respect trashed those drawings saying
they're creepy they're hacky it's awful
terrible art be what happened was they
just became too mainstream and people
got sick room and they trashed him and
then they immediately took it down after
they think they commissioned her to
[ __ ] paint the goddamn thing I mean
what what a [ __ ] shame one article
it's like you like that [ __ ] you like
that [ __ ] and then you walked you
commissioned that artist you told her
how much you [ __ ] liked her and you
appreciated her work
and one little [ __ ] article what did
you do all of a sudden you were like a
[ __ ] kid in high school who wasn't
strong enough to say yeah I'm friends
with that snot-nosed kid over there
right and stayed with them you know you
did they just stepped away and they
watched that lady get stuffed into a
[ __ ] locker with all that goddamn
paitings after what the [ __ ] happened
her and her husband I'll tell you right
now that that's reprehensible all right
Captain America everybody a Billy Bruce
Banner I don't imagine you're sending
spending your free time reading comic
books yeah I can't get into them I
really like the way their drama and I
also like the superheroes always have
like [ __ ] they have like the hottest
girlfriends at least the ones that I
read
spider-man's girlfriend was [ __ ]
ridiculous Jesus Christ the [ __ ]
titties ass and legs I mean she was she
was [ __ ] amazing beautiful beautiful
goddamn woman that's why I don't like
the movies you know what I mean
because nowadays I think they got to
make sure they can't go to [ __ ]
pretty now or else all the fatties get
[ __ ] upset that's an impossible image
I go to the [ __ ] gym do I [ __ ] cry
when Brad Pitt takes his shirt off maybe
I do but I don't tweet about it all
right I don't imagine you spending your
free time reading comic books bill but I
thought I'd share some news with you man
it was revealed months back the Captain
America was actually a Hydra spy all
these years Hydra is basically the Nazis
what all right it was assumed that they
would write it in that he was actually
he wasn't actually a spy this whole time
but was pretending to be well this month
they decided to make it so that Captain
America is and has always been a bad guy
the story elements they are adding our
trash so it's not even a cool twist oh I
love there anything better is there
anything better than the [ __ ] the
pissed off comic book reader with the
direction that taken this story you like
that [ __ ]
Dolores Claiborne whatever the [ __ ]
name is misery whatever the hell her
name was I wish you did I hope what else
are they supposed to do he's been a good
guy for a hundred [ __ ] years and I
would tell you right now you [ __ ]
comic maybe gonna read the rest of us
you guys have uh you know out of respect
I'll regal su sentences here he goes I'm
not a staunch Republican let's [ __ ] at
my screen I'm not a staunch Republican
or a wild southerner I'm just a guy who
is tired of this self-hating trend
what's with people hating tradition so
much that they can't stand a hero just
being a hero oh I see you went a
different direction this is goodbye
ready okay I think you'd like some of
the newer comic titles pictures and
words and some good stories makes for an
easy stimulating read just don't read
Captain America love you love Mia
Congrats on the little lady thank you um
sir what you're dealing with here is
money that's why they're doing it they
have exhausted every [ __ ] possible
story story line you know what I mean
like you remember the Brady Bunch when
they had to bring in Oliver right
remember like remember happy days like
after a while like Ron Howard he just
left it's just like there's nothing left
to do with this character I'm out of it
Mohsen funds he started wearing suits he
was teaching a mechanic's client he
became a teacher it's [ __ ] hooligan
riding a motorcycle next thing I know
he's pulling up in a station wagon
teaching this [ __ ] guy with blond
hair how to [ __ ] tuna carburetor he's
actually helping them with their
problems all of a sudden it became like
Welcome Back Kotter
it's because they were out of idea that
it had run its course and I hate to tell
you this but Captain America has run its
[ __ ] course all right they're going
to get themselves out of this all right
they'll do the classic thing that you
know it wasn't actually the real Captain
America it was [ __ ] somebody else but
the thing is do you we should really
blame is Al Gore he's the reason that
this is all going down because as we all
know Al Gore invented the internet he
said it himself
he said it himself and he said it again
all right the man invented the Internet
and the Internet you know gave birth to
[ __ ] Napster which gave birth to all
of these things where people could watch
movies and [ __ ] for free right Napster
obviously was music but the other [ __ ]
people go on Pirate Bay they just watch
all these movies for free so what
happened was that killed the [ __ ] 30
million to 70 million dollar movies like
they just went away so then everything
became either super [ __ ] cheap or a
hundred million dollar superhero [ __ ]
movie where it's like all right we're
going to just spend all this money and
people going to go because they're going
to want to see special effects in you
know at the movie screen that's what
happens so and they made 9,000 of these
[ __ ] movies and there's nowhere else
to go with them
I think they made a couple of Captain
America movies didn't I don't [ __ ]
know but now what they're going to do is
they're going to set this up that now
this guy is actually a [ __ ] Nazi you
know and who was doing all this great
stuff in America I don't understand she
was like saving children while spying on
us I don't know they could somehow gonna
try to explain all of that [ __ ] I have
no idea but eventually he's going to
fight Batman all right we all know that
Batman has one professional fight under
his belt and he's all for one right he
lost his Superman so before he gets
another shot at the title I think he has
to fight somebody else who's he going to
fight you know it can't be Lex Luthor
and [ __ ] the octopus guy I mean those
guys that played out all right they're
all punch-drunk spider-man's been
[ __ ] them up for years if they need
somebody nope so this is the only way to
go all right I would be surprised if
Vince McMahon does not sue them for this
story like because he did this would
call Kovan like 50 times you know you
know Hulk Hogan was was you know when he
was the bad guy I loved because he would
die the side of his beard he would die
that [ __ ] black and then he would
have the [ __ ] blonde mustache which
by the way I thought looked really cool
he had a great [ __ ] cool Manship he
still does
you ever see guy go bald more gracefully
than that he just kept pushing it back
like Richard Rawlings and every time he
did it it was a little further back you
know and he started wearing the [ __ ]
the scarves and always come off [ __ ] I
don't know tanned his head up he looked
great me when you say that how Cogan
went bald very gracefully would you say
you don't think so what's wrong with you
today
I feel like you don't like me I mean
part of being married some days you're
not going to like me I feel like that's
one of these days I don't understand how
you're so loud with slippers on oh she
said that's why I don't like you all
right princess Kate's fines parenting
hard well I imagine when they try to
play hide-and-go-seek in that castle
it's going to take forever hey Bill get
a lot of this crap Kate Middleton the
[ __ ] princess did a speech in which
she says she finds it hard being a mom
now I'm sure she has a busy schedule but
for Christ's sakes she has servants I
know she doesn't even have nannies she
had servants she may have one of the
easiest jobs in the entire world she
wasn't born to royalty she married into
it so all she needs to do is not be a
[ __ ] for the next 50 to 75 years stay
married and she's all set attached is a
link to her full speech you can listen
to it if you care to listen to it I'm
not listening that [ __ ] she's trying to
promote mental health awareness which is
nice but did she really need to try to
tell us that she finds parenting
difficult huge fan from Newfoundland
Canada thanks and don't forget to go
[ __ ] yourself yeah I mean you know this
is the thing when a kid comes into your
life yeah there's an adjustment period
so she was sitting there getting fanned
by feathers and all of that [ __ ] right
having somebody bring a little Dagwood
sandwich and she's sitting on you know
the little Louie the 15th [ __ ] I
don't know Ottoman is that a word is
that a piece of furniture it is isn't it
or is that an empire
um yeah then all of a sudden the kids
there and she has to pretend to give a
[ __ ] about it for you I think it just
makes her photoshoots more difficult
what does she name her kids they
probably gave him some old white guy
name like Winston Evan these are the
[ __ ] 19th or some [ __ ] that I have to
be honest with you like that has to be
the most boring [ __ ] life you could
ever [ __ ] live being a [ __ ]
princess at least when you're a prince
you know you get to eat a [ __ ] guy
goes around he flights helicopters he
was in the goddamn army you don't I mean
goes out he does [ __ ] right hangs out
with the boys he smoking cigars what'd
he do was a princess once you're [ __ ]
married you know you bro down on the
white horse you had your [ __ ] your
wedding right everybody shows up you
know all the women in the crowd giving
you the evil eye because they wanted to
be a princess all the haters you know
there's nothing good about that right in
you know because it's either going to be
haters or people just sobbing because
that dreams never going to happen for
them since I sees people staring staring
[ __ ] daggers at you
next to fatties and [ __ ] weirdos like
oh she's so beautiful I would think it
would be hard to be a princess I see
steam mind-numbing ly boring [ __ ]
life that you're going to live you know
to the to the [ __ ] this is when you know
you're bored is when you promote a cause
you know you're so [ __ ] bored you
have to go out and help somebody you're
so [ __ ] all set is not what if
there's nothing to do you know there's
nothing you we got everything you
[ __ ] want is this yeah the end game
over now what do you do now you got to
[ __ ] you got to go down to some
third-world country start installing
plumbing or some [ __ ] and you got it you
have to do something either that or you
just [ __ ] you just become like one of
those Dudley Moore characters you just
get shit-faced every day that's what I
would do
take up like archery and [ __ ] I just be
in the backyard just [ __ ] shooting
stuff walking around with some [ __ ]
ridiculous cognac I would be such a
piece of [ __ ] you know I really would be
i if you know it can you get written out
of the will can you get unfuckin prints
X prints or something like that
excommunicated from it that's exactly I
would be oh my god I would have all the
[ __ ] sports packages I go to all the
[ __ ] games alright I won't give a
[ __ ] either I would be I would be
[ __ ] ridiculously blowing the money
and like that would be my goal in life
like how overt can I be with the English
tax people's money that what am I trying
to say the English taxpayers money there
we go
you ever seen somebody like dyslexic
when they're just talking I think I'm
trying to read this [ __ ] I always flip
words around and by all means all of you
who aren't doctors please diagnose me
and tell me what sort of fish oil and I
need to take to cure it that's what I
would do I would just like my goal be by
the time I'm 40 - I want them - I could
easily do that I can easily do that I
could get X [ __ ] you know you no
longer a Duke you know you know it would
be great
you know it'd be great the people would
actually love you I would say with done
hating you the second you walk into a
pub you have no more security anymore
you just come walking in you know yeah
well you're a [ __ ] that one up did you
get touched to be like ya did I had a
great time though [ __ ] was I supposed to
do living in a castle you'd [ __ ] we'd
you know that would be it the next you
know you're sitting in the bleachers
right in the [ __ ] pit at the footie
games just being a regular guy getting
[ __ ] hammered eating fish and chips
and just laughing just laughing at how
bad you [ __ ] up your life and all
those [ __ ] sad sacks they love you
anyways fat yoga instructor a Billy read
sack I don't know what it struck me so
funny I mean I see it every day you
think that would be an old joke I work
out here in LA as a personal trainer and
teach them
yoga classes here and there I've been
teaching yoga at this studio for over 4
years and I got this fat ass [ __ ] for a
manager built she's got to be 80 pounds
overweight and despite being around all
this healthy lifestyle she has done
nothing to improve herself I'm talking
donuts and cookies and I [ __ ] love
this person oh my god I love both of
these people I love that you're calling
her out for being fat or him out and I
love that this person sit there [ __ ]
eating doughnuts in a yoga yoga shop
what'd he call it Studio a studio a dojo
crib I'm talking donuts and cookies in
the studio lobby around people that are
there to avoid these temptations that's
[ __ ] hilarious anyways I've kept my
mouth shut for years but recently we had
our annual class review where the
manager comes and sees how how you class
how your class is put together and how
you are with the students etc this whale
couldn't even get through the first 15
minutes she was beached on her mat belly
she featured a mat belly-up gulping
[ __ ] water oh she wanted to yes she
went into whale pose then afterwards she
had the nerve to criticize my class that
it wasn't challenging enough oh my god
and you didn't say anything
okay this is their reason the grudge is
being held
okay the should say the reason the
reason the grudge is being held is that
my aunt my annual raise was a mere 30
cents and I wonder if that criticism
affected it
give me that Billy burb philosophy under
the situation love the podcast
congratulations on the baby it was great
hearing her on the podcast the other day
go [ __ ] yourself fired nips Jesus Christ
really coming at me with the [ __ ]
redhead [ __ ] today on you I think the
whole thing is [ __ ] hilarious I got
to ask you something all right you've
been doing this [ __ ] there for over four
years I why don't you eventually
start your own thing at this point you
know get out from that this is what you
know what I would do if I was you get
into good graces man you know just start
bringing a doughnuts I bring a fudge you
know and just you know I don't know if
the cops could prove it but just kill
her kill her with what she loves kill
her with kindness okay there you go kill
her with kindness just keep what you got
to do okay this is the thing about those
fatties is that they can handle
doughnuts all right but I'm telling you
right now nobody can handle fudge fudge
is like it's like oh it's almost 100
percent sugar it's like a solid form of
cotton candy but like chocolate in it I
mean it is [ __ ] you can't even eat it
like you hope face puckers up this is
what you do you come in and you make a
tray of fudge all right you cut a piece
out this is what you do okay you cut a
[ __ ] piece out all right and just you
know give it to the birds or some [ __ ]
right I think sugars good for them I
can't remember see the good or it kills
them either I just give it to the
[ __ ] birds right then you bring the
fudge in this and now it looks like
somebody took a piece if she's not going
to feel guilty I guaran-fucking-tee you
I guarantee you do that and the sugar is
going to [ __ ] with your joints all right
then you come in with some bacon some
sandwiches you just keep going sugar
salt sugar salt sugar salt okay and just
you know that 30 cents they should have
given you you take 30 another 30 cents
out of your [ __ ] check every goddamn
hour all right and you you put it
towards giving this person food that
will slowly kill him there you go or you
get a new job I don't know I just I just
think killing I'll be funnier
all right disowning your daughter a
Billy Bathgate
would you ever disown your daughter if
she brought home a dot dot dot dot dot
dot dot hack comic no Jesus think of the
happiest type of comic you can think of
and in the future she brought him home
talking about how she loves him and now
he's the funniest comic ever
uh how good he's got a YouTube channel
tells jokes with the lampshade on his
head etc she asks you what you think of
him
you tell her he's a hack she gets mad at
you tells you you don't understand him
and now he's funnier than you would you
disown her and tell her she can't bring
the hack and it was out now
no jokes Leif yeah joke thief he can't
come in the house you can't come into my
house as a [ __ ] joke thief um I this
is what I would do you know even even if
he stole [ __ ] jokes I know he's going
to get caught and people going to call
him out on it I wouldn't say anything
alright because I'll tell you this I
I've seen how that goes down when you
say you don't like somebody that your
kid likes you don't I mean and then
there's all those in love problems
alright this is your job as a parent is
you got to trust your kids
decision-making all right
they love the guy you just got to go
with it you don't I mean and then if
they get divorced you can't be like hey
you know I you know cuz why didn't you
[ __ ] say something because you'd hate
me um
Jesus why would you bring that up I'm
just I'm three months into this I want
to enjoy my my daughter growing up Jesus
Christ you already got me picturing of
being at the [ __ ] wedding you know
the guy would have some [ __ ] crazy
colored [ __ ] bowtie but cumberbund
alright I don't know Jesus Christ what a
way to end by the way how about the
Celtics not coming back one in two games
how lucky could we get with Rondo going
down Jesus Christ by the way he pulled
off a short sleeve suit I don't know how
he did it he actually [ __ ] looked
cool I think you had to have a cast on
to make it work though like you did he
[ __ ] up his thumb of some [ __ ] alright
Patrice dear Billy big tits
hey I'm losing weight yet [ __ ] found
this on YouTube almost [ __ ] myself
laughing thought you'd appreciate this
some classic Patrice hope you enjoy and
go [ __ ] yourself I will definitely
retweet this thank you for sending that
in you know it's always great that
people are still watching this [ __ ] and
I'm always talking about them that
the stuff that keeps his comedy alive I
know that's all cliched stuff but like I
was talking to I was actually talking to
bartnik and Andrew last night about him
in the green room and I was just talking
just saying how just what I'll [ __ ]
just still like crater comedy [ __ ]
crater
what a [ __ ] loss that was man it's
just that guy was so much he was so much
better than all of us
it was [ __ ] ridiculous and I'm
telling you even in even as great as
elephant in the room is I'm telling you
he he effortlessly could his next
special would have been at least [ __ ]
30 percent funnier than that one that's
the trajectory that that guy was on and
[ __ ] kills me man [ __ ] kills me so
anyways that's the podcast for this week
I'll check in on ya on Thursday please
check out return of the Mack the first
couple episodes have streaming on
something I don't [ __ ] know anymore
very funny and my apologies to Joe
McIntyre for standing you up last week I
really [ __ ] that up and he quitting
y'all worst part he was totally cool
about it because no one know where he's
brother so I can't don't worry about it
and all that that was the worst I was
like can you least be mad at me
something
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'm
check-in on you on Thursday